as if there weren't other things for
Russian MPS to worry about right now but
no this is apparently just the moment to
tighten the screws on Russia's lgbtq
Community
foreigners even just showing a rainbow
flag has been illegal since 2013 making
life on the streets more dangerous for
many now that law has been expanded to
include all age groups this attack on
gay rights part of what Vladimir Putin
likes to depict as a culture War Russian
Traditional Values versus what he's
called the outright Satanism of the West
the gay scene in the big cities was
pretty vibrant and this law does not
call for the closure of gay clubs
still many thousands from the community
have already fled the country not keen
on mobilization into Russia's
notoriously homophobic Armed Forces
says the rhetoric has hardened since
February this year
is
foreign
Jana says she's been able to live fairly
normally as a lesbian woman in Moscow
and she hopes this law won't change
things
um
[Music]
are you scared to speak as openly as you
are
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
how Russia decides to prosecute this law
remains to be seen through a barrage of
cases or just by scaring people into
self-censorship because it's the fear of
what might happen that keeps people in
check here ever tightening laws you
don't want to get tangled up in
Diana magnese Sky News Moscow